antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier pour préserver le droit de
grève c'est françois mitterrand qui
parle
allusion directe vous l'avez compris à
la décision du tribunal de bobigny
déclarante illicite la grève des
navigants d'air inter le président s'est
refusé à tout autre commentaire
pas de jugement sur le jugement at il
déclaré
face à nos jours sans contrôle militaire
une semaine après les émeutes contre la
pénurie
depuis cinq ans la roumanie s'enfonce
dans une situation économique
catastrophique
wall street réagit mollement à l'accord
sur la réduction du déficit budgétaire
américain le dollar s'effrite
la bourse de paris gagne un point et
demi les menaces de la mafia colombienne
après l'arrestation d'un très gros
bonnets de la drogue s'il est extradé
vers les états unis
ce sera la guerre totale avec les
autorités du pays une journée
supplémentaire de détention pour marcel
carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
la france restera présente dans le golfe
aussi longtemps que la situation
l'exigera petite phrase signée andré
giraud qui en dit long sur la
détermination du gouvernement
en toile de fond il ya bien sûr le
conflit franco iranien et la situation
des otages français en iran et au liban
pour le ministre de la défense
il n'est pas question de décrocher du
golfe persique entre guillemets ni même
de sa région
il l'a confirmé sur le porte avions
clemenceau au cours d'une visite éclair
reportage françois cornet c'est une
exclusivité antenne 2 durant ces 24
heures aux abords du détroit d'ormuz
andré giraud oracle fait tout vu pour
mieux analyser la situation sur zone et
prendre le pouls des 3000 hommes partis
le 30 juillet dernier de toulon tout
rassuré vie si la mission de présence et
de dissuasion qui leur a été assignée
hélitreuillage abords de l'orion
derniers bâtiments de la force anti
mines françaises chargées de nettoyer
l'entrée du détroit présents dans la
région et qui pénétrera prochainement
dans le golfe pour identifier les zones
sensibles
l'orion avec deux autres unités à
neutraliser depuis son arrivée une
dizaine de mines
grâce à ces plongeurs ou à ces engins
téléguidés depuis des dizaines de
pétroliers japonais français allemands
italiens américains ou panaméen
mouillez ici au large de fujaïrah dans
la tente d'un chargement pour protéger
les navires de commerce français dans
leur traversée du golfe
un chien de garde de la marine nationale
le doubs d'art de la grée vigilance et
dissuasion
c'est la mission de ces bâtiments qui ré
l'ordre en cas d' attaque d'un navire de
commerce français dans le golfe de
riposter s'il était témoin d'une
agression de la part des vedettes ou des
frégates iranienne un peu plus à l'est
dans golfe d'oman
le groupe aéronaval fer de lance de
cette dissuasion qui en est maintenant à
plus de 120 jours de patrouille
opérationnel depuis son départ de toulon
le 30 juillet dernier le ministre de la
défense a rendu hommage aux trois mille
hommes du porte-avions et de son escorte
partie quasiment sans préavis en
situation de crise grave dans le golfe
et qui sont depuis mobilisés dans cette
région après avoir assisté au
catapultage ou aux appontages des avions
de combat andré giraud accompagné de
françois fillon le président de la
commission de défense à l'assemblée
nationale a tenu à saluer les bouchons
draps du clemenceau les mécanos ceux qui
effectuent le car au fond par des
températures en mer d'oman de près de 50
degrés des équipages qui ne savent pas
aujourd'hui où combien de temps encore
ils sont là je dirais pas que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui la même phase de
tension que celle qui vous a conduit à
envoyer le groupe
mais enfin il n'ya pas nous n'avons pas
observé jusqu'ici les signes de détente
déterminant qui nous permettrait de
changer le dispositif
il n'est donc pas question pour
l'instant de rapatrier ce groupe pas
aujourd'hui mais j'espère que ça viendra
en attendant le retour du porte-avions
puisqu'on ne peut pas le relever faute
d'une deuxième unité actuellement en
refonte à toulon on essaiera de faire
tourner les équipages pour garder ici
des unités opérationnelles
frêche note du terran twitter on note un
regain de tension dans cette région du
golfe persique deux incidents auraient
encore opposé des vedettes iraniennes à
des hélicoptères américains les
américains annoncent par ailleurs la
découverte de cette mine les engins se
trouvait juste sous la surface prêt à
exploser au contact du premier navire ce
matin un porte containers panaméen et un
bateau roumains ont été touchés ils ont
été attaqué par des vedettes rapides
iraniennes non loin du détroit d'ormuz
il n'y a pas eu de victimes parmi les
membres d'équipage
en france la décision du tribunal de
bobigny déclarant illicite la grève des
navigants d'air inter suscite une
avalanche de réactions réactions du
monde syndical
nous y reviendrons longuement tout à
l'heure réaction également au plus haut
niveau
certes le président de la république ne
formule pas de jugement sur le jugement
je disais tout à l'heure mais il évoque
la sauvegarde du droit de grève
écoutez le pour moi président de la
république
m'exprimant dans le cadre de ma fonction
qui en l'occurrence se trouvent l'épousé
très étroitement ma conviction
personnelle
il me semble que il faut rappeler que
tout principe constitutionnel prévaut
sur les autres expressions du droit s'il
devait arriver que par la loi la
réglementation finissent par nis et le
principe dont elle serait sensé
s'inspirer je pense que les pouvoirs
désigné à cet effet et en particulier le
mien ne manquerait pas de demander
raison au conseil constitutionnel jean
leclerc françois mitterrand s'engage sur
le terrain social c'est un vrai clin
d'oeil aux syndicats
oui je crois qu'il y a dans les propos
du président la république un rappel
doublé d'un averti
ce moment solennel le rappelle c'est le
président garant de la constitution qui
le fait tout principe constitutionnel
dit il et l'on sait que le droit de
grève est inscrit dans la constitution
prévaut sur les autres expressions du
droit c'est à dire la loi les règlements
ou même un jugement
l'allusion au tribunal de bobigny paraît
clair même si le chef de l'état a
précisé auparavant qu'il n'avait pas à
juger les jugements l'avertissement
concerne lui une éventuelle
réglementation de ce droit de grève
actuellement celui ci est très floue la
constitution indique seulement qu'il
s'exerce dans le cadre des lois qui le
réglementent or ces lois n'existent pas
philippe seguin a récemment évoqué la
possibilité de combler ce vide pour
faciliter le travail de la justice
françois mitterrand prévient donc
solennellement que si la loi venait à
contredire le principe de la liberté du
droit de grève
ils demanderaient raison conseil
constitutionnel bref il ne resterait pas
inerte pour reprendre une ancienne forme
le chef de l'état fait ainsi coup double
il réaffirme son rôle d'arbitré de
garant des libertés et il répond
favorablement à l'inquiétude et à la
demande d'intervention des syndicats
tout en rappelant pour faire bonne
mesure que la grève doit être utilisé
avec beaucoup de doigté
merci gérard revenant au jugement de
bobigny côté syndical les réactions se
succèdent après les propos très fermes
d'edmond maire ce week-end qui avait dit
ce n'est pas aux juges estimé si une
revendication est raisonnable ou pas
aujourd'hui nouvelle mise en garde signé
henri krasucki épaules marquées - à
partir de maintenant chaque fois que se
posera un problème d'ordre social ou
d'ordre économique puisque la justice
intervient de cette manière je vais
m'adresser à elle chaque fois qu'un chef
d'entreprise va faire de mauvais
investissements
je vais le traduire en justice chaque
fois qu'un ministre va se tromper de
décision je vais le traduire en justice
et nous aurons ainsi la république des
juges on est en train de transformer
l'action syndicale en un délit
poursuites devant les tribunaux
condamnation lourde à des amendes à des
peines de prison
matraquage licenciement s'il est
important de protester il est encore
plus important d'agir et la cgt ont une
décision
aujourd'hui nous faisons du lundi 30
novembre une journée d'actions avec
arrêt de travail limitée d'efforts et le
plus génie possible et des
manifestations de masse à paris et dans
15 pays et je le dis aux autres
organisations syndicales
et pourquoi pas vous voilà l'appel est
lancé dans un communiqué publié
aujourd'hui la direction d'air inter
précise que sa demande de référé ne
visait qu'à fait respecter un accord
signé par les syndicats et non à porter
atteinte au droit de grève
fin de citation la sphère lüscher suite
pierre mauroy l'ancien premier ministre
s'est exprimé il ya quelques minutes sur
les antennes de france inter dans face
au public
petite phrase sans équivoque vous allez
l'entendre il n'y a pas eu de ventes
d'armes à l'iran
l'ancien premier ministre vous allez
entendre ses propos prend ses
responsabilités dans cette affaire
moi je pourrais vous dire que cette
affaire lui cher si à quelqu'un qui
n'intéressaient par la sphère du cher
c'est moi
moi j'aime autant vous dire que je
voudrais bien savoir à quel échelon
on n'a pas appliqué mes directives ça ça
m'intéresse
et ça ça me concerne quand j'étais
premier ministre et instructions ont été
données et vous n'avez jamais même
on ne m'a dit que l'été les soupçons sur
scène j'étais contrarié à quelque
question que ce soit dans le département
du rhône la sphère de radio nostalgie
sur le terrain politique d'un côté il y
à l'inculpation et la mise sous mandat
de dépôt de pierre alberti le patron de
la station
de l'autre la saisie de fausses factures
qui auraient servi à financer la
campagne du parti socialiste en 1986
olivier lerner opeth op es4 lettre sous
lesquels les spécialistes de la police
judiciaire ont découvert une agence de
publicité lyonnaise bien compromise à
travers un petit jeu de fausses factures
pour le ps dans le département du rhône
montant global de ces fausses factures
qui ne correspondent à rien un million
de francs un jeu de fausses factures qui
aurait servi à payer une imprimerie
lyonnaise maître d'oeuvre des affiches
de là
payne socialiste placardées dans le
département du rhône
début mars 86 une dizaine de sociétés
lyonnais se sont prêtés à ce petit jeu
et c'est ici que l'on retrouve radio
nostalgie qui aurait ainsi réglé
plusieurs factures d'un montant total de
100 mille francs soit 10% du trafic
découvert jacques boyer ancien directeur
de lopes accuse nommément yvon deschamps
d'avoir servi d'intermédiaire une
confrontation à opposer les deux hommes
jacques boyer a pour l'instant maintenu
ses déclarations
par ailleurs cette affaire est marquée
par un différend juridique le procureur
de la république de lyon vient de
demander au srpj de cette ville de se
pencher spécialement sur cette nouvelle
affaire de fausses factures
le juge fait né chez quant à lui
autorisé à poursuivre son enquête sur le
passé de pierre alberti et le montage du
radio de radio nostalgie montage
filandreux par excellence la bande fm
toujours dans une autre affaire à paris
cette fois le juge grelier inculpé
aujourd'hui pascal valérie radeau chargé
de mission à la cncl de trafic
d'influencé monsieur valéry radeau
responsable de l'attribution des
fréquences aux radios privées de la
région parisienne avait été suspendu de
ses fonctions par la cncl le 22 octobre
dernier politique c'est l'heure des
comptes au lendemain de l'élection
cantonale partielle de marseille dans
les bouches du rhône
pour beaucoup il s'agissait d'une
élection test je vous rappelle que le
candidat de la majorité est arrivé en
tête avec 36 4% des suffrages devant le
candidat socialiste 28 68 % le front
national 18,3 et le pc 11 66 bref le
front national arbitrera sans doute le
second tour
pascal arrighi député front national des
bouches du rhône il y est allé de sa
petite phrase ce matin il faut qu'on
nous fasse des mamours at il dit et oui
on est loin de la terminologie politique
traditionnelle laurent boussier avec 18
circulent 34% des voix le front national
apparaît d'ores et déjà en position
d'arbitré pour le second tour de cette
élection cantonale partielle entre le
candidat rpr udf arrivée en tête mais
avec seulement 36 4% des voix et une
gauche pc + ps qui en totalise 40 points
35%
ce sont les amis de jean marie le pen
qui feront la différence si jean claude
gaudin affirme haut et fort qu'il ne
demandera rien au front national pascal
arrighi député et patron
local du front ne perd pas une occasion
de rappeler que pour obtenir ces voix la
majorité devra faire des mamours et des
gentillesses à son parti ce n'est que
demain dans l'après midi que jean marie
le pen annoncera la position officielle
du front national alors qu'à gauche le
pc pourrait appeler à voter pour le
parti socialiste
dimanche prochain le second tour des
élections cantonales partielles de
marseille risque de prendre toute la
valeur d'un test national sur les
marchés financiers le compromis
intervenu entre la maison blanche et le
congrès sur la réduction du déficit
budgétaire américain est loin d'avoir
réglé tous les problèmes
a priori le dollar est hésitant et les
bourses irrégulière à noter tout de même
une légère hausse à paris de l'ordre de
1 5% à new york l'accord signé en fin de
semaine est loin de provoquer
l'enthousiasmé général dans les milieux
d'affaires on affirme notamment que
c'est trop peu et trop tard
wall street est tout de même reparti
timidement à la hausse cet après midi
confirmation avec paul nahon à new york
wall street a réagi de façon extrêmement
prudente à l'accord budgétaire de
washington le dow jones à l'ouverture a
perdu plus de 12 points avant de se
redresser très lentement
en fait ici tout le monde attend
l'approbation par le sénat et la chambre
des représentants de l'accord de
réduction du budget fédéral
tout se passe comme si chacun voulait
gagner du temps dans cette bataille qui
dépasse largement le cadre économique et
financier il faut bien comprendre que
l'amérique est en année électorale le
président reagan est attaquée toutes
parts y compris par les sénateurs
républicains ces sénateurs qui doit se
présenter également au suffrage
populaire en novembre 88 et qui répugne
à annoncer leurs électeurs une
augmentation des impôts sous peine de ne
pas être élu et l'augmentation des
impôts tout le monde est d'accord
maintenant est la seule solution à la
réduction du déficit extérieur des états
unis
la roumanie après les émeutes tous les
témoignages qui nous parviennent de
brasov font état d'incidents très grave
et tous les observateurs parlent d'un
divorce flagrant entre le pouvoir et la
population roumaine les manifestations
qui apparemment n'ont pas contrarié
l'emploi du temps de monsieur ceausescu
le président roumain est arrivé
aujourd'hui au
r en egypte comme frais en attendant la
roumanie pays pilote de l'europe de
l'est il ya une vingtaine d'années est
devenu le plus mauvais élève du camp
socialiste
à l'heure de la transparence et de la
démocratisation cher à monsieur
gorbatchev le président ceausescu table
sur la terreur policière
on est très loin du courant réformiste
georges bortoli il se fait appeler le
compte du quator le guide ou encore le
génie des balkans nicolas ceausescu en
compagnie de sa femme hélène et de 16
autres membres de sa famille qu'il a
placés à des postes clés et depuis 22
ans le m adulé et glorifié du peuple
roumain
mais ce peuple parfois se révoltent je
vais le cas le 15 novembre à brasov où
les émeutes ouvrières ont fait au moins
deux morts dans le service d'ordre des
émeutes de la faim dont les roumains ont
faim depuis plusieurs années le
ravitaillement de cesse d'empirer le
lait les pommes de terre le pain mêmes
sont devenus des denrées rares
un forge de patienter on perd patience
surtout quand au bout de la tente on
découvre des comptoirs vide
surtout quand les salaires constamment
la mine et deviennent tellement bas
qu'on doit acheter les piments à l'unité
23 millions de roumains ont faim et de
plus en ce début d'hiver ils ont froid
plus de charbon coupures de gaz et
d'électricité la température maximum des
appartements étaient plafonnés par
décret à 12 degrés l'année dernière
cette année
les roumains ont été prévenus il faudra
la baisser davantage georges bortoli
certains disent que la faillite
économique est à la mesure de l'échec
politique de monsieur chaouch est ce que
vous connaissez bien la roumanie qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
je crois que la faillite politique
résulte de la faillite économique
il fut un temps où monsieur church et
souhaitait un petit peu le chouchou des
occidentaux parce que sa politique
étrangère était assez indépendante de
moscou rappelez-vous les visions
spectaculaires que lui rendirent le
général de gaulle le président nixon
notamment aujourd'hui a plu à soul dans
les casses roumaine et monsieur
ceausescu ne peut plus se permettre la
moindre velléité d'indépendance parce
qu'il a besoin forcément de la des
sociétés alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
il s'est passé que dans les années 70 je
me cherchais ce trou à mener une
politique
l'industrialisation accélérée assez
mégalomane dix ans le mot après quoi la
roumanie se retrouve avec 7 milliards de
dollars de dettes et me chercher ce
colis mais ça ne fait rien nous allons
rembourser nos dettes très très vite
parce que les roumains le peuple romain
on va faire les sacrifices que je lui
demande quels sacrifices et bien par
exemple les ouvriers de brasov ont
appris en octobre que leur salaire était
amputée à peu près des trois quarts il
leur restait pour le mois d'octobre
700 l'oeil ça fait à peu près de 290
francs alors ils se sont révoltés sont
faits les manifestations mal gré mal gré
la police roumaine qui est assurément la
plus dure de tous les pays communistes
d'europe et il al'appui quand même de
monsieur gorbatchev
enfin c'est la tille véritablement
officiellement il a comme audi nous
verrons merci voyons rapidement les
autres télégramme de l'étranger avec
pascal besnier
à genève fin de la première journée des
entretiens touché varna faisait avant le
sommet reggane gorbatchev du 7 décembre
est détendue les deux hommes il ya
quelques instants conversations directes
et constructive at il déclaré brièvement
les résultats demain a ajouté georges
shoot le secrétaire d'état américain
s'adressera à la presse
spectaculaire opération anti terroriste
à la frontière des deux irlande une
quarantaine d'arrestations dans les
rangs du cygne frame la branche
politique de l'ira
cette opération anglo irlandaise vise à
trouver les caches d'armes des
terroristes irlandais pendant une
semaine de 1500 soldats et 4000
policiers fouilleront tout le pays
incendies est prise d'otages les mutins
de la prison d'auxerre sont des réfugiés
cubains
il retiendrait encore 24 personnes tout
a commencé vendredi soir les etats-unis
et cuba venait de signer un accord
d'extradition pour 2500 d'entre eux ils
ne veulent pas retourner à cuba
d'autres incidents ont éclaté atlanta
images de très beaux salvador la
communion d'un amnistié roubaix namora
lui vice-président du front démocratique
révolutionnaire de retour après sept ans
d'exil au dialogue et la paix la
croisade de ruben à morales un des
responsables du bras politique de la
guérilla salvadorienne celle ci a décidé
une trêve jusqu'au 24 devant jorge luis
ochoa bastiaise un colombien considéré
comme le plus gros trafiquants de drogue
a été arrêté en colombie pour être
extradé aux états unis
une arrestation qui ne passe pas
inaperçue car l'intéressé est l'un des
hommes les plus riches du monde
interpol qui tient congrès en ce moment
à nice serait pour beaucoup dans cette
arrestation
thierry calmette depuis des années les
experts de la lutte contre la drogue
conserver ses photos dans leur dossier
relevait luis ochoa contrôler 80% du
trafic de la cocaïne vers les états unis
sa spécialité racheter la drogue
cultivés à bas prix en colombie son pays
d'origine pour la revendre au prix fort
sur le marché américain
sa fortune est estimée à près de 18
milliards de francs il était devenu l'un
des hommes les plus riches du monde
sa chute est le résultat de la
collaboration entre les polices
américaines et colombienne les services
américains de répression du trafic de
drogue dispose d'une antenne en colombie
nous travaillons quotidiennement
collaboration étroite avec la police
colombienne
nous partageons nos informations et nous
utilisons les méthodes que nous avons
déjà éprouvée aux états unis les
etats-unis ont demandé l'extradition
d'aurore et luis ochoa réplique des
trafiquants de drogue
ils ont menacé de déclarer une guerre
totale à la classe politique est ré
justice colombienne
au cas où cette extradition serait
effectivement décidé ariane 18 heures
après le tir réussi on s'inquiète dans
les milieux spécialisés il faut dire que
l'un des panneaux solaires du satellite
de télévision allemand n'a toujours pas
été déployés et un satellite comme celui
là avec un seul panneau solaire ou
lavaur et ça fait un peu désordre
le problème est de savoir maintenant
si on peut encore intervenir réponse de
jacques violet méticuleux comme des
chirurgiens pencher sur leur chair
satellite des ingénieurs avaient
pourtant tout vérifié répéter cent fois
sur terre avant le départ le déploiement
de ses grandes ailes solaires dans un
premier temps quelques heures après la
mise en orbite
on déverrouille les panneaux qui sont
repliés c'est cette première opération
qui n'a pas eu lieu
cette ouverture se fait de façon
pyrotechnique un petit verrou qui
explose soit le satellite n'a pas reçu
l'ordre donné depuis la terre soit le
crochet coincés depuis 48 heures on
réfléchit pour trouver des solutions par
exemple secouer le satellite en allumant
ses moteurs ou bien l'exposer au soleil
pour le réchauffer l'ouverture
définitive des panneaux se fait dans un
deuxième temps cinq jours plus tard
comme on déplie une carte routière
pour l'instant tout le monde garde
confiance ces panneaux solaires servent
à l'alimentation électrique du satellite
sur tv sat une puissance énorme
plus de 3000 watts prix littéraire 1987
suite le prix femina et le prix médicis
ont été attribués aujourd'hui le femina
à alain absire pour l'égal de dieu
paru chez calmann lévy le médicis que
vous allez découvrir après au belge
pierre martens pour les éblouissements
publié pour seuil c'était donc
aujourd'hui à paris de nouveaux prix
littéraire le femina et le médicis
le sport jean ma mère toujours huitième
à l'atp yannick noah alors c'est pas la
peine de jouer faire des jaloux quoi
sert de jouer yannick noah est toujours
8e par contre henri leconte qui a joué
beaucoup lui on a gagné une place il est
passé de la 22e à la 21e c'est
malheureux alors si rien ne sert de
jouer d'un certain côté il faut par
contre courir et ça c'est en automobile
ouais puisque le rallye du rac se
déroule en ce moment en angleterre c'est
la dernière épreuve du championnat du
monde
une épreuve importante surtout pour
l'écurie italienne lancia puisqu'elle
court après deux titres celui des
marques qu'elle a pratiquement acquis et
celui par dont celui des pilotes
et il y a deux pilotes de lancia qui
sont en course mark hughes allen et juha
kankunnen le tenant du titre
tous les deux sont finlandais et croyez
moi la luttre en ce moment est
particulièrement âpre alors premier
miracle dans ce rallye du rac est bien
c'est que tout simplement dans la nuit
très fraîche galloise il ne pleut pas en
revanche il neige conséquence le leader
du premier jour mark hughes allen se
retrouve sur le toit une grosse poignée
de secondes perdues mais cela ne stoppe
surtout pas l'ardeur de l'écurie
italienne dans sa course au titre
au petit matin la spécialité du royal
automobile club est de retour la pluie
et le ciré lancia est toujours devant et
si ce n'est haleine ses concubines son
coéquipier qui occupe la tête quand une
haine très à l'aise au milieu des
spectateurs et sur la terre battue de
vence désormais allen son plus sérieux
rival de une minute 24 les rôles sont
inversés tic boom puisque sur ford
sierra connu quelques ennuis et
rétrograde à la 5e place avec un retard
de trois minutes 15 secondes mais le rac
n'a pas fini de réserver des surprises
et de provoquer d'ici mercredi
encore quelques éclats voilà on l'a vu à
l'instant sur les images y avait de la
neige en angleterre il y en a aussi en
normandie jose 1
c'est un peu inhabituel d'ailleurs nous
avons des images que de tourner ce matin
en normandie dans l'art et autour de
deux camps effectivement cette neige est
tombée ce matin leur attention danger
sur la route cette neige mêlées à de la
pluie voire à de la grêle est redoutable
à d'ailleurs provoqué le télescopage
meurtrier de deux véhicules alors
méfiance demain matin car cette neige va
récidiver comme vous le voyez est bien
une perturbation continue de tourner en
rond au-dessus de la france résultats
des nuages à profusion de main et sur la
moitié nord ri
en plus des ondées surprise sur le sud
est beaucoup beaucoup de pluie de la
neige à partir de 1000 mètres dans les
alpes et sur la moitié nord
attention donc ces chutes de neige en
très basse altitude encore demain matin
quelques rayons de soleil mais vraiment
timide de l'aquitaine au languedoc
roussillon où la tramontane se fera 60
kilomètres à l'heure enfin neige aussi
dans les pyrénées les températures sont
en baisse lente mais sûre 5 degrés à
paris à reims à nancy 4 à strasbourg 4,6
à limoges à grenoble 12 tout de même
encore demain mardi 24 novembre
pensez à flora priorité à l'actualité
merci josé priorité à l'actualité et aux
images nous recevons à l'instant même
des images d'atlanta où une nouvelle et
mode vient de se déclencher dans une
prison commentaires de jérôme boni c'est
aujourd'hui la prison d'atlanta en
géorgie qui est à son tour touchée par
la colère cubaine le mouvement fait
tache d'huile
plusieurs incendies ont été allumés dans
le pénitencier situé en plein coeur de
la ville encerclée par pompiers et
policiers
il est difficile actuellement d'évaluer
l'ampleur exacte de la mutinerie mais il
y a eu des coups de feu et trois
personnes évacuées dans des brancards à
l'origine de ces mutineries cubaine dans
plusieurs prisons du sud des états unis
l'accord passé entre washington et la
havane la semaine dernière pour le
rapatriement de 2500 de ces immigrés la
plupart d'entre eux sont des délinquants
condamnés pour des délits commis aux
états unis ou incarcérés pour leur passé
criminel à cuba tous font la
démonstration violente et spectaculaire
dans les prisons de géorgie du texas de
louisiane de leur refus farouche de
retourner dans leur pays mais bien si
jérôme d'autres précisions ce soir dans
le prochain rendez vous d'information 24
heures sur la deux avec aubry et de
l'air à 23h25
demain dès 6h45 n'oubliez pas télématin
avec le trio c'est la kbl hautement à
7h45 c'est bernard pons le ministre des
dom tom qui sera l'invité des 4 vérités
il sera évidemment beaucoup question du
statut de la nouvelle calédonie qui fait
suite au référendum
bonsoir et à demain excellente soirée
sur antenne 2